hi everyone good afternoon
thank you for joining us at our good
design research grant briefing session
today
my name is victoria from design
singapore council and i will be your
event mcm moderator for today today's
session is brought to you by design
singapore council and it is supported by
our challenge statement partners the
lively places fund team from both the
urban redevelopment authority ura and
the housing development board hdb
and additionally we also have with us
the singapore civil defense force and
cdf as well as terror so private limited
you're probably here today because of an
interest in the good design research
grant while you are at the right place
apart from discovering everything that
you need to know about the grant
including tips on how to put in a strong
proposal we have our challenge statement
partners from ura hdb scdf and tara so
here with us today they will be sharing
on their respective challenge statements
we also have the strategic futures team
from dsg who will share on the open
challenges related to the lovable
singapore project
so here is the program that we'll be
going through later
so before we kick off with an exciting
lineup ahead please allow me to
highlight a couple of housekeeping rules
firstly if you encounter any technical
issues do not hesitate to reach out to
our friendly tech team through the zoom
chat function below
and then additionally if you have any
questions at all throughout the session
please drop them the questions in the
zoom q a module below as your audio will
be on mute when posting a question do
remember to state your name as well as
company if applicable and then indicate
if your question should be addressed to
any specific speaker
without further ado let me introduce our
guest speakers along with this
afternoon's program
there are many ways to apply for the
gtdr grant one of which is to address a
real world challenge from our partners
who will be sharing about their specific
challenge statements today firstly we
have with us mr clifford oh young
clifford is an architect from the urban
design west department at ura secondly
we have mr shafiq ong who in coordinates
innovation development in sdf and
thirdly we have with us mr joseph tan
founder and ceo of terosaur private
limited a local startup that focuses on
smart and sustainable solutions joseph
will be joining us just a little shortly
apart from addressing the challenge
statement from these wonderful partners
you can also consider responding to
dsc's open challenges and my colleague
ms janine liu will be sharing more about
the challenges later
finally you can also consider submitting
a self-initiated proposal in your
application for the gtr grant as such i
will be bringing you through these
different application routes along with
some tips on putting a strong proposal
together in the later part of the
briefing
we will end off with time for q a to
address any pressing queries that you
might have so do stay till the end
now let's start off by inviting clifford
from ura to share more about lps
challenge statement on using design and
community engagement to enliven public
spaces clifford's portfolio work
includes developing urban design
guidelines for these central west and
north regions of singapore as well as
projects under the euroa public space
program with the aim of creating a more
livable and lovable public realm for all
let's welcome him
thank you victoria for the introduction
and good afternoon to everyone so i'm
clifford from the urban redevelopment
authority
singapore's land use planning and
conservation authority which formulates
the long-term plan and master plan to
guide the physical transformation or
development of singapore as part of
today's briefing on our join challenge
statement with hdb i will be sharing
more about how and why we plan for
public spaces
so the ura develops the long-term plan
to guide the strategic direction of land
use across the country for the next 40
to 50 years so that's the long-term plan
which by the way do keep your eyes
peeled uia will be launching the
exhibition summarizing the engagements
and proposed long-term approaches
in a couple of months and every five
years we also revise the master plan
which is the detailed statutory plan
that guides developments for the next 10
to 15 years
so we guide the land use like
residential open spaces park so and so
forth and as well as the development
intensity which basically means how much
floor area can be packed into the land
puzzle
so we take a long-term comprehensive and
integrated planning approach to ensure
that sufficient land is safeguarded
and so
planning for public spaces is a very
integral part of the planning process
and if left to the market
users with higher commercial value could
price out users such as parts and open
spaces
in fact the planning of public spaces is
considered upfront we even use them to
structure our city to help define the
district character
so that brings to the question of what
are what are public spaces so here are
some examples of public spaces in
singapore you have parks ceremonial
greens water bodies promenades plaza
squares urban rooms void decks
courtyards so on so forth and these
spaces might be sheltered or open to sky
very green or not so green state owned
or owned by public are sorry by private
developers but they share some things in
common
they are like the living rooms of our
city
and are places for encounters and
environments for interactions
and by very definition of his name you
know
public spaces are meant to be open and
accessible to all
and the in the urban planning context
they also reinforce the city's urban
design
sorry the urban pattern and help to
orientate one's movement in the city by
being points of reference
so the planning design activation and
management of public spaces is important
to us
as good public spaces foster community
cohesion
provide a more livable and lovable
environment and enhance the quality of
life including our mental well-being
creating better public spaces through
community engagement can strengthen one
sense of ownership identity and
emotional connection to the area in the
space
so making better public spaces are
really an essential part of your ace
planning work and that can also be seen
from our plans such as the parks water
bodies and public spaces planned that
marks out the designated parks water
bodies public spaces right and we work
with agencies to provide key public
spaces and also with the developers to
provide public spaces within their
developments
also many key teams in our last master
plan in 2019 touch upon public spaces
and community engagement
so in summary public spaces could be
improved to address
p for programming such as activities
that can take place within the public
space thereby encouraging social
interaction and that could bring
economic vitality to a place
l for landscaping adding greenery can
improve the physical environment and
make the place more livable
a for accessibility
universal or barrier-free access is
important to encourage active living
c comfort in all senses of the world it
has to feel safe be physically safe and
comfortable such as by providing shade
and sitting to contribute to the sense
of comfort and well-being
e for engaging
an attractive place with delightful
highlights engages the five senses and
the mind and that can be appreciated by
all as for social inclusivity because
everyone has a right to be included in
public spaces so we hope that everyone
can feel a sense of belonging to the
shared place so all of this make a place
and so here's our challenge statement
how might we use design
design and community engagement to
eleven public spaces
so we would like to encourage applicants
to investigate one of or more of the
following
one how to create an attractive engaging
and lovable space that appeals to our
senses and provides a sense of delight
and comfort
two
how to create a sense of inclusivity and
encourage social bonding and mingling in
public spaces
three
how to promote taxable users or programs
in public spaces
we are looking for research output that
has evidence-based methodologies the
proposal should involve the physical
transformation or intervention of an
existing open space
and should also show how communities
could be brought together through
activating public spaces quite
critically
we would also like to see in the
proposal how the installation if it's
built
could be easily implemented and
maintained by the community members
at this point we would like to highlight
that the ura and hdb jointly run the
lively places fund which is an all year
round funding program to better support
community lab efforts in eleven
singapore's public spaces
we'd like to share that shortlisted gdr
proposals that also meet the eligibility
criteria for the likely places fund are
also eligible for additional funding
from ura or hdb to implement the
proposal as actual installations in
public spaces
so that's the qr code which you can scan
to find out more about the likely places
fund but let me share with you the key
points from the fund
so critically the funding criteria for
lively places fund is that the
implemented project has to bring
communities together through activating
and creating delightful public spaces
the project has to be initiated planned
implemented and maintained by the
community members and stakeholders
the project also requires match funding
from the community for at least
30 percent of the amount of funds
applied for
for instance if uia or hdb is going to
provide ten thousand dollars of
something of funding support as for the
likely places fund project the community
has to provide
three thousand which is thirty percent
of ten thousand
and that can be in volunteering or
professional man-hours equipment or
other supplies that are meant to
implement the installation
in terms of how much we are looking at
we are looking at
up to twenty thousand dollars for an
installation of a list of at least six
months
therefore the total funding for your
proposal can be up to seventy thousand
fifty thousand for the research
component under
good design research and the twenty
thousand dollars from ui or hdb to stage
the installation for a six month
duration
so i'm showing the qr code to
the website link again
so at this point i like to share in
terms of how gdi lively places fund can
go hand in hand
here is a suggested timeline
so
shortlisted proposals for the gdr have
to complete the
the project within 12 months right
so there's a 12 month period under gdr
during that time uh the successful
applicant can seek guidance or advice
from ui or hdb for the project
as we are the project sponsors
um according to gdr you have a midpoint
check in after the first six months and
during that time we can
start to assess the eligibility of the
project for the likely places fund
and at the end of 12 months
you are supposed to submit a proof of
concept for the gdr so at that point
you and us being uia or hdb can make a
decision on whether to continue to
implement the project in public spaces
as a lively places fund project or you
can leave it as a research project
so do note that the gdr proof of concept
deliverable may be a prototype design
and it may not be fabricated if you
do wish if you so wish
or it can be other output depending on
how you want to frame your research such
as you know
frameworks or guidelines etc
however the lively places fund
deliverable it has to be a physical
installation in the public space
so that's the qr code on the screen to
find out more about the eligibility
funding objectives
of the likely places fund and the sign
up form
so to apply for the likely places fund
please submit the form that you can find
via the qr code there so hdb or uia will
walk you through what's necessary over
email or we'll call you
so we just need to understand what's the
project where is it located how will the
community be involved
and so on so forth and we'll
subsequently guide you along the way on
the various aspects to fulfill the
objectives of the likely places fund
and that's typically on how to involve
the community meaningfully in the
project and also the appropriate
property owner or manager to engage
when the concept or implement and the
implementation approach are settled we
will inform you that we are in principle
supportive of the project and with that
you can proceed to detail the project
and obtain cost estimates with the cost
estimates then we will be able to enter
a formal agreement with you in which uh
ura or hdb will reimburse up to the
agreed amount which is the earlier
imagination twenty thousand dollars for
six month long project and then you can
carry on to implement the project in
public spaces and with that i've come to
the end of my presentation thank you
thank you so much clifford we will now
invite shafiq from scdf to share more
about using design to strengthen scds
digital engagement and management of
external stakeholders to build a nation
of life savers prior to his role his
current role shafik had spent three
years in frontline operations and is a
pioneer scdf's first smart fire station
at pongo he now coordinates innovation
and development in sdf ranging from
ground up initiatives to ops technology
experimentation and proof of concepts at
the organizational level he's passionate
in exploring new technologies and
learning more about human-centric and
data-driven designs over to you shafiq
thank you so much victoria uh yeah hi
everyone i'm shafiq from scdf yeah
thanks again uh for attending the brief
and thanks to victoria for the
introduction so
let me
jump ahead for our
presentation all right so basically for
those who are unfamiliar with the scpf
uh i hope not many of you are unfamiliar
with us
we are one of the few emergency
organizations globally to provide the
full spectrum of emergency services of
firefighting rescue hazardous material
or hazmat mitigation and pre-hospital
emergency medical care both on land and
sea
we closely partner relevant stakeholders
to formulate implement and enforce
regulations
on fire safety and civil defense shelter
matters
so essentially our ultimate mission is
to protect and save lives and property
for safe and secure singapore
so
however we must continually adapt and
evolve to meet the challenges arising
from an increasingly complex operating
and
environment
our transformation vision 2025
that is the nation of lifesavers serves
to support the attainment of scdf's
mission through service excellence
so for the scope of our gdr challenge
statement which we will go through later
this brief will focus on two of the
three strategic outcomes that we see on
the screen
that would be the enable empower the
community and institutionalize safety
and public protection
so the fact of the matter is that every
day scdf is in a battle against time to
meet our mission
and while we invest in technology and
innovation to level up our operational
capabilities we need to recognize and
reconcile re-conceptualize what we
understand as resources beyond our scdf
forces to meet future demands
and this is why raising community
preparedness is the foundation for
building an emergency ready nation we
need to galvanize the public to render
first response to emergencies while
waiting for scdf's arrival at the
incident site
to this end we need to develop a
comprehensive community outreach and
public education framework that targets
various segments of society
it is also equally important for us to
move our services upstream to
reinforcing and infusing the concept of
fire safety prevention and public
protection as a pro-enterprise
organization scdf needs to balance
between regulating to improve this
resilience of infrastructures to fire
hazards and adopting a collaborative
whole of community approach to fire
safety to shape and internalize
behaviors
so in essence our approach is to
regulate fire safety and public
protection as a preventative measure
prepare the community for emergencies
and respond swiftly when an emergency
does happen
now that you have a better understanding
of our transformation vision and
approach do allow me to set the stage
for our challenge statement
our current state
is that with a variety of external
stakeholders or customers who come with
different needs and require different
types of services we face a challenge in
designing a holistic and engaging
experience for all various digital touch
points have been developed to serve
specific needs of the time
and this would mean that
sorry however this means that an
individual may need to find and navigate
multiple touch points if they seek a
variety of services from scdf
and because different departments within
sdf govern their respective service
domains this could result in
inconsistent stakeholder experiences in
terms of communications and branding
here are some of our existing digital
touch points which you could use as
reference for your proposal
first we have the myresponder mobile app
which is used to activate community
first responders to nearby minor fires
and cardiac arrest cases to close the
gap in mitigating risks and rendering
aid before scdf's arrival
there are also public education
materials and scdf publications in the
application
next we have our web portal which serves
general needs across different domains
such as file safety consultation civil
defense shelters national service
matters committee emergency preparedness
and public education
we also have our social media pages
on facebook instagram and linkedin to
digitally connect with the community
particularly the social media users to
bring across public education
messages and insights to our operations
so there is impetus for us to design
targeted and holistic engagement with
our stakeholders
for this gta call we will focus on the
emergency response and incident
management ecosystem
so the very first group of stakeholders
come from the community who render first
response to emergencies while waiting
for scdf's arrival at the incident site
for example we have committee first
responders who are activated via the my
respondent mobile app
to
nearby minor fires and cardiac arrest
cases we also work hand in hand with
community emergency and engagement
community communities or c2 east in
short to organize community resilience
days and fight safety awareness visits
in the heartlands
our volunteers include the civil defense
auxiliary officers who assist us in
various services domains such as public
education fire safety enforcement and
even in operational capacities such as
firefighters and emergency medical
technicians
we also have the aed on reveals
programme which is a collaborative
effort with companies like grab and
comfort delgo as well as committee first
responders to increase the availability
of aeds in the community
having these life-saving aeds on the
move can help to improve a cardiac
arrest victims chances of survival
the next group of stakeholders come from
our industry and commercial partners
who help scdf to reinforce the
importance of safety and public
protection within their companies and
across the industry
first we have defy safety managers or
fsm's
who helped to ensure and enhance the
fire safety standard within their
buildings
through the fsn fire safety activities
such as tabletop exercises and physical
fire drills as well as fire prevention
measures are also implemented to promote
fire safety awareness among the building
occupants
we have the
company emergency response teams assets
who support the fsms
and are equipped with the knowledge and
skills to handle five hazards to
mitigate the outbreak of fires and to
render first aid and cpr aed
the next group the next subgroup would
be the build environment professionals
and fire safety professionals who work
together to prepare building plans or
propose five safety works in any
building in accordance with the
regulations made under this fire safety
act
these are
registered architects or professional
engineers
whom building owners can consult in
addition these professionals help to
carry out inspections of fire safety
products that may be involved in their
works
they would refer to the fire code which
they can access on our web portal and
they can also work closely with scdf
directly through our file safety
department
so to really sum up what we i just
covered in terms of the stakeholders is
that
we recognize this business use case to
adopt a stakeholder centric mindset
across scdf's services
where we are deeply aware of a
customer's end-to-end journey with us
and are equipped with the tools and data
to optimize their experiences with
interacting with scdf
so essentially we are looking for
experiences which should be engaging and
consistent across the board
so to introduce our challenge statement
how might our design strengthen scdf's
digital engagement and management of
external stakeholders to build a nation
of life savers
there are two prompts
of which the first one is how to design
a digital ecosystem that harmonizes and
streamlines the digital experiences of
various external stakeholders as they
interact with scdf
so in other words how might we
consolidate existing and future digital
touch points to provide a seamless
experience to any user
so you should consider leveraging the
existing sdf my respondent mobile app
and web portal as reference material you
may take this chance to scan the qr
codes on the screen to download the my
responder app which you can explore
later on
so other than activating the committee
first responders
i also mentioned that there are also
public education materials and sdf
publications accessible on this
application
here's the qr code for our sddf web
portal
so our web portal just to reiterate what
i shared earlier is that it serves
general needs across different domains
such as file safety consultation civil
defense shelters
ns matters committee emergency
preparedness and public education
so the type of proposal that we're
looking for we very much welcome
persona driven and user-centric
proposals that enhance the existing
experiences uh by consolidating
consolidating the different services
onto a common ecosystem or platform
we are also very much uh looking out for
creative solutions that introduce
entirely new experiences
uh and even resources for our
stakeholders perhaps to encourage
self-service or even to better foster
voluntary participation and compliance
to regulations
importantly we are looking for proposals
that leverage digital experiences that
are harmonized and streamlined for
consistency
we also have a second prompt
which is how to design a data-driven
process to profile and manage a
stakeholder at the individual level
based on the interactions with scdf
in other words how might we build a
holistic profile of each unique
stakeholder for their respective
departments to access and better
understand the interactions with scdf in
terms of the end-to-end journey
so here are some things to take note
each
individual stakeholder may hold multiple
identities uh and can act in different
capacities with different needs
throughout their lifetime so here's an
example
you can be a member of public who is
also a community first responder who
uses the moba the my respondent mobile
app but you are also a file safety
manager in your own company
and you may have certain kind of
interactions with scdf perhaps in terms
of file safety enforcement and uh
operational surveys at your premises
we are also uh
something next thing to take note of is
that proposers should also consider
scdf's need to use and visualize data to
harness insights to effectively further
engage and activate stakeholders
so to clarify on this
on this part uh it's not so much on
understanding directly the type of data
that stdf needs but
more to how we can visualize the data
perhaps in terms of dashboards so that
this can help
sctf eventually to potentially tailor
content based on the unique personas and
profiles of different individuals based
on
the data insights
so we recognize that there are many
stakeholders even within the different
groups
so you uh proposers may focus on
selected stakeholder segments as you
wish
but must demonstrate the scalability
across the wider ecosystem
so uh i've come to the end to our brief
we look forward to your innovative
solutions to drive our movement to build
a nation of life savers through digital
experiences thank you
thank you so much trafik next let's
invite joseph from taraso to share about
using design to address the issue of
glass waste in singapore joseph is the
founder and ceo of terrasol private
limited a startup that focuses on smart
and sustainable solutions he is
passionate about employing smart
technologies like automation and the
internet of things for sustainable zero
waste outcomes in the circular economy
prior to taraso joseph held various
roles at credit suisse fortis and
standard chartered bank joseph also
serves the community as a district
councillor of southwest community
development council let's hear more from
him
okay
[Music]
so good afternoon everyone i hope
everyone has had a wonderful long
weekend
and quite excited to share with you
today in terms of what terracol does
uh thanks again victoria for the
introduction in terms of briefly what
terasol does as a company we were we
started in 2013
and our focus is primarily on two
pillars one which is using smart
solutions
in other words
technologies like the internet of things
robotics and automation
uh to repurpose down dangerous jobs
so basically you know using technology
to enhance the way we live the way we
work
and that falls primarily under the smart
pillar today's sharing is under our
second area of focus which is on
sustainability so we are always on the
lookout for good ideas good solutions
that is able to you know perhaps change
the way that we live our lives to make
um you know living
on a much more sustainable
basis
so
before i you know talk about the problem
statement i just want to give a bit of
backdrop
in terms of the waste landscape here in
singapore so if you look at this pie
chart in front of you
these are some some of the data that
we've extracted from the national
environment agency and it's good data
that goes back some 20 years
what essentially i've pulled out from
you know that data set is that
you are looking at the waste that ends
up in
our incinerators in singapore so there
is
another group of ways which has got very
high recycling rates and they are you
know things like construction debris
uh you know metals
rubber tires those get well recycled in
the sense that their recycling rates are
more than 90
but these are the ways that typically
have got recycling rates that are less
than 90 and end up in our incinerators
and consequently in our landfills so you
can see you know through this simple pie
chart that we have got four areas that
contributes a significant amount of our
waste that ends up in our incinerators
they are primarily food waste
paper and cardboard waste
plastics
and horticulture and wood waste of
course the horticulture and wood waste
is a bit of an adjustment to the data
from nea
because quite a number of our
waste in that category is sent to waste
to energy plants in other words we burn
the horticulture and wood
for energy but if you take out the
unburned portion then you realize that
mechanical recycling of that particular
waste category is actually fairly low so
we still have only got some six percent
of the the waste in that category that's
being recycled so the percentages that
you see are the actual recycling rates
in all these different categories
and the figures that you see those are
the tonnage
on an annual basis in terms of how much
waste is actually being incinerated and
consequently buried in the landfills now
um why today's focus and i'll share with
you later on is primarily on that little
green slice that you see which is glass
even though its proportion
as a contribution to the greater pi is
relatively small
but glass in particular
has a lot of
interesting
should we say
characteristics that make it very
challenging to tackle as a waste
material the rest if you look at food
horticulture paper they are fairly
organic and they will degrade on their
own over time or they get burned quite
quickly uh plastics is the one that is
really quite challenging because as you
know burning of plastics releases a lot
of dioxins to the environment and that
is not good
but plastics is hard to tackle because
it is not homogeneous there are many
different types of plastics as indicated
by the plastic numbers types that you
see it typically in terms of a drink
bottle
or a shampoo bottle and it's not easy to
tackle the plastic
space but today we're just going to
focus primarily on glass
moving on
so this is the same data but stretched
over a time series stretching back to
2003 and you can see that the
amount of glass waste is generated in
singapore is fairly consistent uh
they're about 70 000 tons on a per annum
basis
in terms of the tonnage it is
approximately the same as
electronic waste so it's still quite a
significant uh and a waste type on its
own and if you look at the recycling
rates it has sort of harvard you know
between five percent all the way up to
about 26 percent but of late uh what is
a bit disappointing is that the trend
has been declining so in terms of the
amount of glass waste that has been
recycled we are really looking about
only 10 so of that 70 000 tons
on a
annual basis you are really just talking
about you know perhaps 7000 tons that is
being recycled the rest ends up you know
in the incinerator so what is so wrong
about having glass that ends up in the
incinerator
the problem is you know primarily the
waste to energy incinerators that we
have in singapore they run at
temperatures of between 850 to 1000
degrees celsius
and glass as a material um does not burn
easily
it only liquefies at temperatures of
1400 to 1600 degrees so you can imagine
that a lot of energy is wasted on trying
to burn glass
but glass doesn't burn
very well
and on top of it glass bottles uh on
their own are fairly voluminous it does
not crumple so in other words a lot of
the incinerator space is actually
occupied by these glass bottles which do
not burn and inside them is essentially
air so
what can be better done of course is to
see if we can actually take glass ways
out of the incinerators freeing up more
space for other types of ways that are
combustible
the next problem with glass of course is
that after you know you've gone through
all that process of trying to burn it
and you buried it in the landfill uh it
will take about one to two million years
before glass
naturally degrades so it's a very long
time um and certainly you know the way
that we are sort of managing the glass
waste stream in singapore i'm sure we
can do better on that front
so
fortunately glass bottles can be
transformed
into glass sand mechanically so there
are you know industrial glass crushers
that can reduce uh all these glass
bottles into very fine sand granules uh
no different
from
things like uh beach sand very fine
quality and of course the scent can be
reused for other purposes which we will
cover uh in a short while now the
benefit of this of course is you know we
will
as a nation uh require less sand if we
can use some of this recycled
sand that we generate organically within
our borders and this will help prevent
us from degrading
perhaps the natural environment of less
developed countries when we import said
from those places so there is a story
from law school covering how singapore's
desire for sen is actually affecting the
cambodia's coastlines
uh also we we are very fortunate that
technology is making very quick advances
and you can see that there's a hong kong
study that finds that you know uh glass
sand uh can be used to replace river
sand uh for construction purposes so
fortunately technology is on our side
and we're starting to see you know
innovative use of uh glass sand
of course you know traditionally glass
sand can also be used for a lot of other
mostly industrial but sometimes
recreational purposes as well it can be
used for example in the top left picture
can be used to
pave the roads as a component element of
asphalt
on the top right picture you can see
that
someone that is doing sandblasting so
glass can be used as a abrasive in terms
of surface treatment of metals before
you can apply coating to the metals
bottom left a little bit more frivolous
you can also use the glass hand
for golf courses in the bunkers and also
it can be used for the top surfing of
the uh the top dressing of the uh the
greens themselves and of course you can
also use uh glass as a input component
uh for things like uh cement yeah so
there are different uses of sand but uh
we are not doing enough in terms of
converting the glass waste into the sand
and giving it a second use of life
here within singapore itself now this
all may seem very challenging very
technical that you might you know kind
of be daunted about what what you're
seeing but i would like to share with
you that you know um
perhaps that you know for the recycling
of glassways it's not so much the
knowledge that is required to do so uh
because they're already machines that
are available
and it's certainly you know not so much
in terms of the scale etc or even for
that matter the age so i want to play
you a short video in the next slide
in terms of how two teenagers uh in
america has managed to create a glass
recycling microcosm within their
community so let me try to play this
video
oops
oh dear
[Music]
hi it's megan clawson devin smith so as
a part of our service project we're
working on bringing glass recycling to
our valley um
by crushing this wine bottle we can turn
it into a grit or sand product that can
be reused in gardens um construction
and a lot of other projects too um so
this is our first crushing and we're
gonna turn the machine on
put the bottle in and it'll be crushed
[Laughter]
[Music]
crushing gloss almost
all morning a couple hours at least and
we discovered that
44 glass wine bottles will give us about
50 pounds of sand
glass product
and a huge thanks to the lakeland
building supply for letting us fill and
sell their sandbags at the store in
downtown manson
[Music]
okay so then the video gives a very you
know simple
example of how if you have the if the
heart is in the right place then you can
generate microcosms where you can
actually reduce the amount of waste that
you generate also reusing them
by crushing it into a different material
and again it you know it's just a
creativity that thereafter that applies
in terms of what kind of products
uh can result from the glass sand so i
do believe strongly that in singapore we
can certainly start a movement you know
to get more people excited about
recycling and you know encouraging
people to live in a life in a more
circular manner uh which will help in
you know resulting in a zero-waste
outcome for the economy and our nation
as well and our communities so in terms
of the uh problem statements that we
like to propose
today is you know essentially we have
seen that there is a more sustainable
approach to managing glassways by
crushing them into safe to handle
glasses and of course then this sand can
be used as a raw material for various
inputs whether be it industrial whether
it be recreational and even on an
individual basis
it's just the sky's the limit and it's
only limited by your creativity yeah so
we are
hoping that designers can be encouraged
to research on the following uh what can
we use uh glass sand
for as a potential raw material so this
is what we are hoping that you can apply
your creativity to
um the proposals can explore creating
eco-friendly products solutions
which should be feasible and scalable
and also of course you know we are open
to ideas in terms of how we can
proliferate microcosms across singapore
that is aimed at reusing the glass waste
as generated by local communities to
promote decentralized recycling so for
example it could be a shopping mall that
can put one of these machines and then
you know
people with glassways
can come they can crush the glass
themselves into sand and others can help
themselves to the sand
to bring back and do you know perhaps
even landscaping in their gardens etc so
this sort of microcosms uh we are hoping
to proliferate across singapore so what
we are looking for in terms of our
problem statement and the challenge is
for interesting proposals or prototypes
that might
help us to lessen the negative
environmental impact of the current
glass waste management system that we
have
in singapore
and also if you have got interesting
proposals or prototypes that are cost
effective to implement and practical uh
to end users so that sums up the problem
statement
thank you very much for your time and
may the force be with you thank you
thank you so much joseph
now let's invite janine assistant
director of strategic and governments in
dsg to share about the open challenges
related to the lovable singapore project
janine and her team led the
leads strategic planning and research
projects to support tsu's twin visions
of making singapore innovation driven
and livable city by design this includes
the lovable singapore project started in
2020 which is also singapore's inaugural
study that looks at the livability of a
city beyond livability
janine also drives dsg's strategic
futures initiatives which sports lights
spotlights and sense makes the impact of
emerging trends on singapore design
let's welcome her
hello thanks victoria hi so i'm janine
i'm here on behalf of the lovable
singapore project team to present our
three challenge statements so this is a
multi-agency project with various public
and private
organizations
whilst it's led by design singapore we
also have partnerships with center for
livable cities deloitte center for the
edge hpb and us participate in design
shout out to larry who's in the audience
today
ura and s3 together under mccy
so victoria kind of gave a quick um
background to why we're doing this and
it's linked to our design 2025 master
plan that has two key visions one is an
innovation driven economy and the second
is a lovable city by design
so before we set up to look at how to
design for lovability we first wanted to
unpack what lovability would look like
in singapore today
and this is also quite timely because a
lot of people are currently talking
about what lies beyond livability so
what's the next vision for singapore
this is also of interest to many cities
globally because there is a lot of
research coming up that shows how
livability is also tied to strong
communities resilience
collaboration innovation and also could
lead to building of shared common values
so this started back in
and over the course of um
more than a year we engaged 2 500 people
across singapore
both qualitatively and quantitatively um
asking them two key questions so the
first is what's lovable about singapore
and the second is what will make
singapore more lovable so the first
question aims to understand the enablers
that drive lovability
what we want to protect maintain and
amplify and the second helps us to look
at identifying opportunities to address
gaps so today our three challenge
statements um i think you can say is a
mixture of both
we also put together a lovability
framework from the data that we um
amassed which looks at how people
connect with their cities in six
different ways in
a sense of inclusion connection
attraction
attachment agency and freedom and this
occurs across four areas of the daily
lived experience so our relationship
with public institutions people and
communities
our sense of our own cultures and
identities
and how we relate to our built
environment in places and spaces
so today we've got challenge statements
um around the areas of attachment agency
and also
a mixture of inclusion and connection
so first one is about how we strengthen
our sense of attachment
and the challenge statement is how might
we build a greater sense of attachment
to singapore
deepen our roots and tap into our social
superglue that bonds us across
backgrounds ages and ethnicities
to strengthen singapore culture and
identity from ground up
so this comes from
different factors that that um impact
our sense of attachment so throughout
the
so throughout uh study we found that
there are factors that enhance our sense
of um connect emotional connection and
also factors that lower them so when it
comes to sense of attachment
our respondents told us that these
shared cultural linguistic and
behavioral practices like foods english
uniquely singapore traits like
binkyasukebo
use the tissue to choke seeds these are
what they identified most strongly with
and what they felt um contributed most
greatly to having a sense of attachment
to singapore because it's like perceived
as uniquely aspects of a unique
singapore identity there are also other
factors such as
our society's general acceptance for of
diversity
preservation of visual anchors
shared spaces and also seeing cultural
icons that elicit a sense of pride
so um while once we have you know for
the sake of simplicity we presented
these factors as a as a list i think you
you probably also notice that there are
overlaps maybe one factor impacts
another
so anyone who wants to respond to this
challenge statement can choose to focus
on one or even a combination of factors
so on the flip side what lowers our
sense of attachment is when we lose our
visual and cultural anchors
especially
pertaining to our built environment
when we don't identify certain aspects
of singapore behavior when we perceive
that there is a lack of authenticity
especially in the built environment
so what we are looking for would be
design proposals that explore
opportunities that strengthens and
builds on existing elements that are
already identified as
strong enablers of attachment such as
the social blue
um ways to embed local culture into
everyday experiences and
ways to explore
ways to enhance and embrace
new cultures that are coming into
singapore
the second challenge statement is around
addressing areas that affect our sense
of agency particularly in shared spaces
so how might we enhance people's stake
in places and spaces and equip them with
a sense of agency to develop these
places and spaces
so we have found that our sense of
agency in singapore is enhanced through
these areas i just want to focus a
little bit on the first one
which is this um which is what we found
from our respondents this is already a
strong baseline a strong commitment to a
social contract of shared responsibility
in making
public spaces and interactions safe and
pleasant for all so we found that the
majority of our respondents uh
agreed very strongly that everyone has a
has a part to play in this area so
perhaps this is one area that could be
further enhanced through design
intervention
others are also opportunities to
co-create and shape shed spaces
especially in residential neighborhoods
and also we found that opportunities to
contribute to social causes
came out very strongly um as a result of
the pandemic it definitely
built more avenues to
for for people to get involved in
donating volunteering
etc the last is when there is a good
two-way relationship between public
institutions and residents
which empowers residents to express
opinions and co-create solutions
on the flip side
this is lowered when we feel
disempowered overwhelmed with
regulations that we do not know how to
navigate when we perceive that we elect
knowledge skills and tools we like
change or when we encounter apathetic
attitudes in other people
so when we pulled our respondents we
found that 33 percent actually agree
that they they can they feel they can
make it make an impact on their
neighborhood or in their community
issues uh interestingly almost half
neither agree nor disagree and about
20 percent disagree so we're hoping
through this challenge statement we can
unpack
um the
why why 48
are on the fence or perhaps address the
gaps felt by this 20 percent
hence we're looking for design proposals
that run research at precinct or
neighborhood levels
on how to reduce barriers to co-creation
and also
explore capability building in residence
for ground up engagement and this could
even take the form of building
frameworks or playbook
so the final challenge statement is
around strengthening inclusion and
connection
and the challenge statement is how might
we design for a more equitable society
that promotes a softer definition of
success and how might we further expand
our values of multiculturalism diversity
and inclusivity to fit the growing needs
of emerging groups
so what we found is the sense of
inclusion and connection is enhanced
through strong micro communities in
formal networks that exchange care
support and resources especially so in
neighborhoods
our shared cultural and linguistic
practices
are feeling welcome accepted and able to
partake in civic life especially
in public face spaces that feel
welcoming to everybody and where you
feel um
you you feel that you can linger there
and spend a long time there without uh
being rushed to leave the fourth one is
something that we wanted to uh highlight
a little to spotlight because we felt
like um that there could be design
opportunities here
so this is public spaces or activities
that not to encourage interactions with
people outside our social circle so we
got a lot of um very impactful responses
from our from our study participants
about how
unplanned spontaneous or surprising
interactions with people in public
spaces
that they may normally never interact
with
played a very big role in how they felt
about singapore's lovability
and on on the flip side in the interest
of time or just focus on the first two
this would be when the pace of life
feels stressful or competitive leading
to unfriendly unpleasant public behavior
and also leading to
threat spaces that do not feel welcoming
for everyone
so we're looking for designers
to investigate how we can enhance
inclusiveness
including social infrastructure that
encourages spontaneous interactions or
encounters
how we can reframe or redefine diversity
to update our understanding of
inclusiveness especially as society
becomes more sophisticated and diverse
so underpinning all of this is our
belief that lovable cities are dynamic
human and resilient and we look forward
to
receiving your questions or inputs or
responses can connect with us through
this email over here
and
yeah thank you
looking forward
thank you so much janine
okay now let me
share my screen as well and i can take
you through the
how you can better submit a gdr proposal
i hope my screen is showing up properly
okay let me start then um so if you're
keen to uh thank you thank you to all
our partners as well as the sf team for
going through their challenge statements
as well as the open challenges and if
you are keen to
apply for gdr um here's how you here are
the three different types of proposals
that you can actually put in so the
first one is to actually take on a
challenge statement which is a real
design challenge that you have just
heard about alternatively you can
respond to our open challenges which
journey has also just shared on and
lastly you can actually submit a
self-initiated proposal if you already
have a research area that you want to
look into and you already have it in
mind so these are the three types of
proposals
and then in terms of the types of
support that you can receive if you are
selected for the grant support
eventually
firstly it is the seed funding of up to
thousand dollars to kickstart your
research project and it is co-funding
support of up to seventy percent of
actual cost kept at fifty thousand so
that's just a note to
uh take note of
and um it's for qualifying items so
which i will touch on in the next slide
other than seed funding you also do get
mentorship guidance from industry
experts publicity and capability
development support like media training
for example
and on top of that there could also be
potential business opportunities arising
from responding from responding to
challenge statement partners
additionally there is cross-industry
collaborations potentially with our
resource partners which includes like
prototyping labs new material labs or
even artisanal crafts and finally at the
end of your research projects
there are showcase opportunities dsg is
very active on social media and will
definitely publicize about the research
your research project and you may also
have the chance to have in-person
showcases for example at gardens by the
bay
in terms of qualifying course items
there are five types and
they are mainly material costs which are
materials research required for the
research or the proof of concept
development secondly is third party cost
which is like external consultants
external manpower cost that's required
for your research and proof of concept
it also includes
say project documentation as part of
proof of concept
thirdly there is external venue rental
cost and this is for
should you need to
you know rent out venue to conduct
meetings interviews workshops as part of
your research that will come under that
fourthly equipment and software costs
and this covers subscription purchase
renter etc they are required
and lastly if you're enterprise and
you're applying then we do cover
internal manpower cost but it is
prorated it's the basic salary prorated
based on the time spent on the project
by the employee it is also kept to the
low of 10 000
or 20 of the total actual qualifying
costs
then in terms of our evaluation panel
the ones who will evaluate uh the
proposals receive and select those who
are finally supported by the grant it
would it consists of the permanent panel
with the this for
delisha executive director of deloitte
center for the age asia chiahi head of
design for phillips asean pacific
as well as head of government public
affairs for phillips singapore
isian head of pillar architecture and
sustainability design at supd and
finally christina who brings with her a
wealth of luxury retail experience and
industry knowledge
additionally we do also have the
rotating panel consisting of siemens ceo
of taft as well as chris founder and
creative director of asylum these are
actually subject x uh industry subject
experts who will give their comments as
well as input to support the permanent
panel's decisions
so then what is applied design research
so
in um we encourage applying designers to
really look into practice based research
that explores one or three of the
following areas below
one being systems and processes
second being identity and culture as
well as third being new technologies new
technologies can be both digital and
material and if you look to the right it
we have some examples of the types of
projects we had so far in ranges from
designing community playgrounds of the
future all the way to the other end of
redesigning timber construction to be
more sustainable
secondly
at the end of the project designers
should be working towards a proof of
concept and the proof of concept is not
necessarily a product per se it can it
can also be say prototypes of models
tools a framework a guidebook so it the
proof of concept can take many forms but
it should definitely demonstrate that
you have gone deep into your research
and also that the the proof of concept
has wide applications across the
industries and even beyond singapore
so now is a guide for how you can put in
a strong proposal
this can also be found in our faq on in
the founding application kit on our
website the
qr code is on the top right corner so
firstly summarize your research concept
and objectives an example is for example
this proposal looks at the viability of
deploying an existing reconstituted
material that can be molded into
pre-fabricated building elements for
example
secondly do state how your project
contributes to the impact areas while
addressing global challenges so for
example your project could
contribute to enabling economic
transformation and
it aims to show say with business model
built on superior system and technology
how singapore can benefit etc
thirdly to outline the intended outputs
for your project's proof of concept so
for example
your proof of concept is aiming to have
this this is this concept as a flaw slab
on wall panel to showcase the strength
constructability and
and the cost efficiency for example
fourthly
you can explain your plans to further
develop and publicize the completed
project this could include say you plan
to reach out to other parties you plan
to collaborate with other
industry experts or industry leaders or
say you want to publish it on your
social platform to get a more reach in
the future
and lastly please state how the project
strengthens your unique value
proposition
so um for example it could be
establishing your firm's taught
leadership in a particular area or yeah
so it's it's to so these five um
guidelines we hope will help you
better guide your uh proposal
preparation
in terms of eligibility criteria um it
the gdl grant is eligible for practicing
designers with more than three years of
working experience
all enterprises that have been
incorporated in singapore for more than
three years the lead applicant should be
either a singapore citizen or a
permanent resident
in terms of the evaluation criteria
these are the five main categories um
in terms of strength of proposal
the design impact
the unique value proposition how it
strengthens your
enterprise or your personal unique
proposition your track record which is
actually a
portfolio of work within the last three
years
and finally the design ethos
so in terms of timeline uh i'm sure most
of you are known it has already launched
last monday and the application period
will actually go on for six weeks ending
on third june 2022
6 p.m to be exact and then after the
application period closes the evaluation
will go on for about six weeks and if
you are shortlisted you will be notified
to give a detailed a more detailed
presentation at the final evaluation
session to the immersion panel that was
mentioned earlier
and then if at the end of it you are
finally support uh selected for grant
support there will be a paperwork uh
period and signing agreements for about
five weeks and then the project duration
the project will commence um it's up to
12 months if you are able to actually
finish your project earlier than 12
months and complete your proof of
concept that is fine as well
but in any case there will be a midpoint
check-in with a presentation as well as
a final presentation at the end when you
have completed your proof of concept
ah okay and
so this i've come to the end of my
presentation and these are the contacts
if you have any questions feel free to
reach out to us and these are also the
qr codes that you can scan
which i'll leave it up momentarily
and then um
so finally we want to give our audience
a chance to engage and ask questions
especially if there are questions about
the challenge statements shared today
can i invite the speakers to turn on
their videos as we take some questions
from the audience
okay great let me just take a look at
the
q a section so far okay so there is a
question that is to all panelists how
would you measure the impact for such
design research projects
and um maybe you can kick start with
clifford
hi thanks victoria uh
some measuring the the kpis we want to
see that
because our project is specifically for
public spaces we want to see that
for example there's improved food for or
you could do user surveys to show that
people are more satisfied with the
the area after you have implemented the
project i think it can be kept fairly
broad but we want to see a tangible
improvement which you have to measure i
hope that clarifies
okay then maybe next we can ask shafik
for your thoughts yeah okay so i think
for for stdf's challenge statement in
terms of measuring the impact
what the proposal could uh include uh
plans to
say conduct musical research uh even
running usability tests with our
existing touch points and subsequently
how would your potential proof of
concept or prototype
what are the
the plans to also conduct user usability
tests for those prototypes and
subsequently the impact would be
[Music]
how
the whether there is going to be any
significant improvement between the
existing experiences as well as the the
future
yeah
great thanks shafiq over to you joe
hello thanks uh everyone um i guess for
us the project is fairly straightforward
because you know we are using a raw
material uh which is glaston to generate
prototypes or products um and in that
sense you know every grain of sand that
is converted into a product is a grain
of sand that is kept out of the landfill
so we can measure in terms of how much
actual tonnage
uh you know the product after you have
done the prototype and subsequently as
well um you know project out as well in
terms of the impact on the recycling
rates of glass waste in singapore and
and how much we can actually keep out
the landfill that's that's a very you
know uh straightforward way of measuring
it but another way to measure
you know the kpis if you will uh it's
also the the impact in terms of the
touch points how much of uh you know the
community have we managed to conduct the
outreach to uh how many people and then
the you know in the sense how many
people are coming on board into this
campaign or perhaps even made aware
that you know they can use a glass line
in so many different ways so another way
to measure the impact of course is you
know how many touch points we have been
able to to engage
throughout the period of the project
thank you so much joe janine do you have
anything to add on
hello
so i think this is a really great
question it's also something that uh
we found quite an interesting challenge
when we first set up this project
because it's quite intangible right how
do you measure the increased lovability
of a place so if anyone i think if
anyone wants to respond to our challenge
statements i think a good way to
look at um the impact of your design or
your intervention would be to perhaps
base it on the on the data that we will
share with you on various indicators
that we have hold the public on
and to see whether there's the needle
has moved after after the intervention
so that could be one way another way is
if you want to set up your own
parameters
and devote some of the resources to
running your own survey
pre-intervention that could be
a possibility as well
thank you so much janine um okay then
maybe we can go straight into a couple
more questions for janine uh from sanaya
uh she's actually asking uh how will
definer design or research output be
used further down the line for instance
is there an opportunity for a government
agency to pick this up and scale up on
the prototype later on
yeah thanks for the question that's a
really great question um do i add some
context to the lovable singapore study
we're actually socializing our findings
with various public agencies at the
moment because we found
that um you know across the breadth of
findings that we derived from
the data
there are certain things that are
perhaps more policy driven things that
can only be
um answered or addressed by public
agencies
whereas on the other hand there are
others that we felt were
more um would be more impactful if they
came from ground up rather than top down
so these are the ones that we have
selected for this round of
challenge statements
so uh so we are hoping that this would
spark off a more ground-up response to
the the questions that have been put
forward
so
in the if if there is an opportunity for
you know a pilot
to be further scaled up we will also be
able to
put the designers in touch with the
relevant
um partner agency to see if they can
they want to take it up or further scale
it beyond this project
great thank you jenny and one more hot
on the hues for you
yes
so will we um will well the designer
have access to the report from the past
round of research beyond what is
available on the website currently yes
yes definitely so the reason why we
haven't put the full report on the
website
is uh because some areas are still you
know being looked at by various public
agencies
but
for the purpose of answering these
challenge statements we will make
available the
data behind the insights that were
shared
as much as possible yeah
thank you so much janine okay thank you
all also for all the questions that we
have been receiving some of them we
my colleagues will be replying to you
directly
but in the meantime uh shafiq we have a
question for you would it be acceptable
to submit a proposal that only addresses
a part of your challenge statement for
example responding to sds first half of
the challenge on digital ecosystem but
not the data-driven process to profile
and manage stakeholders
sure okay so yeah thanks for the
question uh victoria so uh i think it's
acceptable it's acceptable to answer
just the first prompt and not the second
or
the other way around uh but perhaps to
clarify how we had crafted the challenge
statement it's really the first prompt
focuses on
once we have consolidated the various
digital touch points
how are we to how are we able to sort of
track and monitor the interactions that
various stakeholders have with scdf
subsequently
that information
would help us to would potentially help
you
in uh
coming up the proposal for the second
problem because
once we know the different touch points
and what are the directions
the number of hits for example
then that data is already being tracked
so how would that data be easily
accessible and visualize for sadf to
sort of
glean some insights right and then make
the
data-driven decisions behind the scenes
and then it becomes a cyclical kind of
process where those insights would also
inform us how we can better improve
those touch points or services uh that
we have for
the different stakeholders so i hope
that uh sort of clarifies uh the
intention of breaking into two different
subprops because uh we're really looking
at a holistic
experience from end to end
yeah so by of course
we are okay with uh proposals that uh
focus mainly perhaps on the the first
part
uh but if you are able to have a
proposal that answers both problems that
would be of advantage to you
thank you so much traffic and um thanks
maybe for joe we would like to invite
you to expand a bit more on your
response to sanaya from quantum consumer
solutions regarding conducting the
research through a more behavioral
change language
okay um thanks victoria for the question
and thanks sanaya for the question
in terms of uh the short answer of
course is yes uh it is definitely
something that you can tackle from the
behavioral uh lens standpoint because we
are doing something that
uh let's we are studying something that
is fresh and has never been done before
in singapore in terms of trying
to create these small little communities
all around singapore where we can do
decentralized recycling so certainly
quite a favorite of the work you know
would require uh reaching out to the
different stakeholders and i'll give you
an example like for example launchpad uh
there is a um a bar over there a pub
called timber and you know you can
essentially work with people there and
say about putting a glass crusher there
getting the glass in and then you know
letting the community use uh the glass
sand freely so people who live around
the area can pick up the glass and for
various purposes so certainly there is
scope to you know look at things from a
behavioral lens to see how you might be
able to encourage um you know and
essentially light the fire
in the community in your hearts so that
they will all be charged up to
participate and this is definitely one
of the
you know challenge statements that we
are cooking putting forth as well in
terms of how can we proliferate uh
microcosms um but also not just in terms
of um
looking at the behavioral change but
also process changes as well you know
how can we change the way that we do
things for example currently almost all
the glass waste is collected by public
uh you know waste collectors how about
we you know engage some of the agency
members
like nea perhaps to try to you know do a
bit of a sandbox uh a playground you
know so that we can try to do things a
bit differently so there is also a need
to you know
put on the good thinking hat and to see
we can tackle things differently via a
process change so i hope that answers
your question
thank you joe
there have been a couple of questions
that have been asked in the chat box and
i believe all the answers have been
posted to them if anybody has uh any
other clarifications that you might want
to let us know in the q a chat and we
will keep this channel open for a little
bit or further to see if anybody has any
more questions
i believe we have just gotten a comment
from
i hope i'm pronouncing your name
correctly so very um that to to joe so
most application that uses glass can
already
be already are replaced by plastics and
the point that you raise that plastics
are diverse
um
oh joe i hope you're able to see the
comment as well so
you can it's easier for you to read
through why i read it out so i managed
to process unsalted waste plastics into
slabs and rods to eliminate wood and
paper a seminar
was organized by mit alumni for
petrochemicals capital houston and that
was held
so glass may make small contribution and
zero plastic waste can make singapore
lead the world is to command by
sovereignty which i hope i got your name
correct so joe if i if you have anything
that you would like to add on to this
comment
and do let us know
yeah thanks uh sophia i i think it's uh
i hope i pronounce it correctly as well
um you know you're absolutely right we
are dealing with
a huge plastic problem that is you know
almost a million tons on an annual basis
um you know i
for this the skill of this uh you know
problem uh i think it's just a little
bit out of reach
for you know this this particular
challenge which is why we have chosen to
put forward something that is more
manageable uh you know baby steps first
but uh you know we are also very
interested in trying to solve the
plastics problem in singapore um and you
know by all means please reach out to me
uh more than happy to have a chat with
you in terms of how we can you know
together perhaps make a meaningful
impact on you know the plastic waste
problem here in singapore
okay great and of course if anybody has
any questions that you would like to
specifically direct to any of our
partners today their contacts can
actually be found on our website under
the challenge statement
webpage and you can reach out to them
directly through email so feel free to
do so um so as i am a little bit
conscious of time let me just share my
screen with the contact details for dsg
and feel free to reach out to any of us
and there's also the qr codes that you
can scan for more information
um we are very quickly approaching the
end of the qaa session so i would like
to thank all the speakers that have been
here with us today for the very engaging
conversation and
again if you have any further questions
on the channel statement feel free to
reach out to them directly
so with this um the briefing session is
actually coming to an end and we hope
that today's sharing has actually
inspired you to consider pursuing
impactful design research in your
practice applications are open now and
will be closing on 3rd june 20 22 6 pm
to be exact so feel free to reach out to
us and if you have any further questions
about the grant or even to share about
the proposals you have in mind we're
happy to jump on a quick call
thank you again for your interest in gdr
and enjoy the rest of your afternoon
thank you everyone